[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's bobby
i'm back in the geek culture studios
talking about a game no no no no not
some rpg game not some latest graphics
card on some 46-inch 4k
monitor to talk about some 120 hertz
gameplay no none of that
we're simplifying it
there's a game inside of this box
it's a whodunit mystery you don't need
to go put a headphone set on
don't need to plug it in
we're going back to the basics folks
from hunterkiller this is their 2021
summer game
it is called
camp calamity
i know i've read some of the comments
from the previous uh videos that we've
talked about hunter killer games a lot
of you said hey these games are so
expensive 150 bucks usd and i only play
it once guess what right off the top of
the bat this game is 60 u.s dollars
and the cool thing is a lot of us can be
sitting at home right now due to the uh
you know the new variant out there we're
not talking about the loki's tv series
we're talking about of course the delta
variants are going to be sitting at home
some of you are going to be forced to be
at home and you want to do something fun
and exciting with your family friends
loved one cousin uncle dog
this is the game you want to check out
now cam calamity is based on the death
of a camp counselor called bradley
brooks now according to the police
report
bradley actually was drunk tripped and
fell into a bonfire and burned to a
crisp
can you believe that i can't i
think it was a murder
toasty without any marshmallows anyway
but not everyone believes this the
camp's owner's daughter gemma thinks
there are some clues out there
that will unveil that this was not an
accident
so you know what time it is zacky this
time
yes
of course
was that
shaggy
this is not scooby-doo folks but we
should do one we should do a version of
that one day but anyway it is time to
dig into camp calamity and find out what
happened to bradley brooks if i do that
you're not gonna want to pay 60 bucks to
watch it and then we don't get any money
out of this video then we're just doing
this for the hell of it so
um by the way if you buy this from our
link below there's no extra cost to you
it just helps out our channel and keeps
us making videos so uh do help us out we
would greatly appreciate that but anyway
i'm gonna show you some of the things
that are inside the box i'll walk you
through some of the clues some of the
details because the one thing that
hunter killer has done really really
well with all their box games as they
have gone
to such extent to recreating the
atmosphere
of these
uh unfortunate victims and what they've
written down the clues how you find
certain things that it just takes hours
to figure out it's creepy as hell it can
scare you if you are a scaredy cat well
don't do this at night you might not go
to sleep because this will take you
through a journey and it might be a
little uncomfortable at times but
it's very cool when you find out who the
killer is if there is actually a killer
or
was bradley just really drunk and stupid
and fell into a bond trying to burn
himself to chris which could happen to
anybody i mean i guess so what if we had
marshmallows but anyway let's take a
look at the box first here i mean the
one cool thing that hunter killer's done
with the box is just the attention to
detail when you look around this i mean
it's like bradley literally wrote on
this box all these little notes and
things that you write on your summer
camp box that you put into your little
log cabin or whatever cabin they have
and you know speaking of which i
my camp counselor i don't think was like
a bradley you know my camp counselor was
hot man she was
anyway young i was very inspired by her
i would run up and down the mountain and
whatever she told me to do it was good
times good times at summer camp anyway
so uh first we've got a lighter here and
it's actually got a phone number on it
and this phone number works now
depending on what country you
order this box from
you know total charges will apply
because it looks like this is an
american number 518-323-9670
don't call it until you get the game
though of course and uh does it work
no it doesn't it's not a real lighter
minus one for camp calamity it's not a
real lighter in the box
it can't be it's a game folks we don't
want kids to burn themselves anyway
moving on we've got um this car that
gives you the uh the game contains 22
items
gem has letters a gemma's envelope with
the following inside whoo
an arrowhead where's the arrowhead let's
find the airplane i like arrowheads man
that's fine let's find the airhead oh
it's in the envelope
look at this
dear investigator please look through
this after reading my letter it's
stuffed and i love the details on this
this is so cool
wow
[Applause]
we got
a paper clip
scratch out thing
looks like oh i remember these calendars
do you remember this we never go to
summer camp look at this i love these
calendars
i remember this you'd have your
different things that you would do
during the day with the different
counselors also we got in here is a camp
flag from camp ashburn
look at this native american motif on
that you can also make it a bandana if
you want so if you want to be more like
you know if you're a biker like a
renegade zach you should put this on
your your honda you could be like yeah
man
what's up
you could be like that
wait let me show you something brother
come on now
yeah anyway so you can wear it like that
if you want but i mean obviously this is
the camp flag is this a clue i don't
know
and also there's this
really kind of weird picture of this
chick
that is uh
at the campfire looks like but there's a
lantern there's a cup
looks like she's drinking something that
she shouldn't be drinking
at camp ashburn
but she looks kind of hot
she's kind of hot tacky what do you
think oh there's a oh
there's a note
she's always perfect she's always right
so why is
sadia
getting drunk at night
took a lot of effort for that guy to
write a poem actually
it's a lot of work actually i mean
not the best but it works
but you know
he's a camp counselor
yeah
not robert frost by any stretch of
imagination but it'll do its job anyway
another clue
[Music]
ah look at the arrowhead look at this
look at the arrowhead this is cool man
this is legit
you know because back in the day people
think that arrowheads were metal but no
i mean the you know the native americans
used rocks
and they actually carved out of the
rocks the arrowheads
this is cool very very cool and this is
legit this is not some plastic arrowhead
this can hurt somebody so be careful
with that you got uh some cards here
with some clues
you got the ashburn fire watch
camp comedy by roscoe pine the questions
and all this stuff oh man it's just the
detail look at this stuff you got a menu
you know would you okay let's see what
let's see what they ate scrambled eggs
gotta have scrambled eggs in the morning
hey zaki you love amsterdam amsterdam
hash browns
bacon oatmeal that's for breakfast lunch
fish sticks
do you really want to know what's inside
the fish sticks or who
bradley had a sense of humor mac and
cheese you're a mac and cheese guy
aren't you oh yeah you love mac and they
got chili
chili but not the chili sauce like here
we have in singapore like proper chili
man
yeah like you mix it up with some beef
and different that yeah beans
like that kind of like sloppy joes
that's right um snack you get ice cream
yeah i have to have ice cream for a
snack i scream you i scream you
you scream we all scream because curtis
is trying to poison us ooh that looks
sounds like a clue
curtis
also fruit been for dinner spaghetti
meatballs caesar salad brownies have you
been teaching other people how to make
your special brownies curtis
zach you ever had a special brownie
you mastered him yeah
i know you have
i knew you have never been though
this is a murder mystery we're supposed
to be serious zacky okay now we've got
this sort of this um this beaded
bracelet looks like something that you
would see from uh
you know when you're in a relationship
hey abby abby come over here come over
here come over here a second what do you
think of this
it's adorable though
adorable it's adorable i love seashells
i i will keep this can i keep this no we
have to play the game it's a clue
but after i find out who killed somebody
i'll give it to you as long as it
doesn't belong to the killer
well it belongs to me
what else do we have in here
we've got some stickers happening here
vomit game over poop pinworm monster
bradley wasn't the most mature man but
it happens to us boys we usually mature
later on in life right abby
thank you see
we have a clue skid we need to talk me
to the campfire after the party ah
was this the campfire
where
bradley was drunk
tripped over and burned himself to a
charred crisp in the bonfire
uh-huh anyway
that's just some of the clues here and
also we want to take a look at the
bottom of this box because this looks
like there's a lot of things here at the
bottom of the box
to help you
in terms of finding out
[Applause]
you're not supposed to see any of that
you didn't see anything anyway this game
i don't want to give away too much but
this game is a lot of fun and it's about
the discovery that's what's the fun part
of this i mean you were used to playing
all these games online now with our
headphones on and shooting up zombies
and
rpg and full on but to go back to the
basics of actually using clues in our
mind and trying to figure things out
this is cool and i think if you want
something different during this uh you
know unpredictable times that we're in
right now and you have to stay at home
or you just want to try something over
the weekend just out of the norm
this game is worth a shot so for more
information click on the link in our
description below on this and it doesn't
cost you anything extra but it does help
out our channel quite a bit if you want
to order from our link so with that guys
this is camp calamity by hunter killer
and you guys are gonna have a lot of fun
don't become too good of a killer okay
because you'll learn how to do some
things that you should know how to do
like
is that a good thing to say
there is the writing quality and the
puzzle design
what's that
yeah so in terms of writing quality that
is really it's paced really well and in
terms of puzzle design it is
incorporated very smoothly
with games like this what tends to
happen is that the puzzles feel forced
inside
as you can tell brandon wrote the
article for this gameplay that's on geek
culture's website so do check that out
he's much more detailed than i am for
more of a detailed breakdown as brandon
has sort of eloquently put this out
there
he's really sort of given you a more
in-depth into the game but i am about
you discovering it yourself because do
you want to find out if bradley actually
drunk was drunk and tripped and burned
himself to a crisp into a bound fire
i don't think it happened
i think he was killed
zack you think he was killed
i don't know
maybe abby you think he was killed oh
yeah she says hell yeah i'm with abby
anyway to find out click on our link in
the description below we're going to
give you 10 off if you use geek culture
use our uh our coupon code geek culture
10 off so instead of 60 bucks it's going
to be 54
usd see my math is pretty good
not the brightest bulb on the chandelier
times but
when it comes to percent off i know what
i'm talking about 54 bucks usd you can
have camp calamity sent to your door
with that guys enjoy the game something
different something unique and i think
you your loved ones and your family are
going to really enjoy playing this
and
you know what if you're going to be like
me you'll probably go to sleep with the
lights on after you're done with it so
it's a bit creepy anyway
with that stay safe take care we'll chat
to the next one
bye
[Music]
you